[Music]
february 13th
2017
kuala lumpur international airport
kim jong-un's brother enters the
terminal
unaware that two female assassins are
also at the airport
now for the first time on television one
of the assassins tells a full
extraordinary
and i story
[Music]
it begins with her being recruited by a
man who claimed to be a tv producer
[Music]
for months kim jong-un's agents groomed
city
and another young woman to ambush
unsuspecting members of the public
and smother their faces with cosmetic
creams in what they thought
were hidden camera show stunts
[Music]
the crap dance
city's handler arranges a meeting at a
cafe in the airport
there she is to receive details of the
[Music]
target
[Music]
foreign
foreign
this time it isn't baby oil but a deadly
nerve agent
as kim jong-un's brother heads to his
flight the two women
make their move
said you
seeking help kim jong-nam heads for the
airport's medical facility
so at this point kim jong-nam is in the
infirmary and he is behind the door
and this is where this image gets very
scary there's a gentleman
in all black walking near this door
okay and he's got a rolly suitcase
he's checking in to make sure that kim
jong-nam is receiving medical
treatment this is one of the operatives
it's a very elaborate operation it's
very old school
the operation plays out like a cold war
spy caper
there are lookout men
a chemist to handle the nerve agent
a getaway driver
and a team leader codenamed grandpa
[Music]
the young women have no idea what
they've done
they are soon arrested by the local
malaysian police
then
the trial creates shock waves around the
world
she's been charged for the most serious
crime in the country the crime of murder
for the offense of murder there's only
one punishment and that is death
by hanging
the chemist of the gang is also
apprehended
he is caught on camera getting his story
straight with north korean embassy
officials
[Music]
this video evidence helped to build a
picture of a ruthless political
assassination
both women were released after spending
two years in prison
[Music]
b
kim jong-un's troublesome older brother
was no more
you